the you a sports festival was one of the
highlights of my year academia so far it
gave us a ton of amazing moments
including the evolution of Todoroki the
one for messages and of course deku
general craziness every year there are a
series of preliminary events that are
randomly generated by a computer and the
students who managed to get through them
then go on to the main event which is
always a 1v1 matchup of some kind now a
couple of weeks ago I made one of my
most popular videos to date which
hypothesize what a next-gen sequel to
Maya academia could look like if you
didn't see that then I strongly
recommend watching it first as today
we're doing a part two but we'll discuss
some crazy potential upgrades to the
sports festival as well as who would
compete and what the best potential
matchups could be just before we get
into it though we are still on that road
to 100k so every single subscription is
very much appreciated okay so I figured
we'd start the video with perhaps the
biggest change that would differentiate
the next generation sports festival from
the one that we already saw as I always
said the event has become even more
popular than the Olympics in Japan but
that wording kind of gives away the fact
that maybe outside Japan it might not be
as popular as we think I mean what
reason were people outside of the
country have to watch a bunch of
Japanese school kids compete when we
know that quote is kind of like a
worldwide thing so yeah I don't really
think there's a reason for people
outside to watch it however what if in
the next generation the US sports
festival isn't just an opportunity for
students to show off their quirks and
their skills to the professionals
but instead it serves as a qualifier for
an international sports festival with
all the top schools from around the
world so think of it like the Triwizard
Tournament or something like that in
this system the final four contestants
of the UA festival they would be
selected as part of an elite squad to
represent UA at these annual global
games
what's more the winner of the festival
is automatically appointed team captain
of their year group this means that they
get to lead the others and kind of make
core tactical decisions during the
international event but if you're a bit
confused I'll use a quick comparison so
if we apply these rules to the first
sports festival that would mean that
back ago Todoroki Tokyo me and tenure
would have represented us
first years in the international
competition we have catch on being the
team captain although he would only be
team captain for the first year group so
each year group from UA has their own
team this would be a great honor for
pretty much any student as all hero
agencies across the planet would want a
piece of you after something like this
now as we all know
arrey would be the main protagonist of
this sequel series and given her humble
personality I don't really think she'd
be hell-bent on winning the you a sports
festival that said as one of the members
of the all my blue group which I spoke
about in the last video she certainly be
one of the favorites to make it into
this elite squad Tami sure is another
one who would also have high
expectations although in his case I
don't even think he'd be nervous for him
it's more of a question of how soon
until I win this thing there are other
students that I'd like to explain before
we get into the one view on matchups but
for now the last person I want to
mention is Kat Zoomer and his epic quote
evolution this is a character who was
first introduced to us in the heroes
rising movie and his quirk is known as
cell activation which in practice acts
like a regeneration quirk and it heals
the injuries of the people that he
touches and gets them back into top
physical condition but I know what
you're thinking how could an ability
like this actually win when it's paid up
against the powerful offensive quirks
that he'd no doubt come up against in
the main event
well what I'm about to say is kind of
inspired by something that I read in the
black global manga but what if consumer
could activate this quirk on himself for
a period of time and during that period
let's say it's about a minute his whole
body glows as his cells are consistently
regenerating and activating this would
make him temporarily invincible meaning
that he can't pierce his skin you can't
burn him he can't freeze him the
downside is that once the time is up he
can actually get very very exhausted so
pretty much like a choco when she throws
up something similar to that but with
that out the way let's get into how
everything would go down in the next-gen
Sports Festival like I said before the
preliminary events changed each year and
being the uncultured swine that I am I
actually had no idea that cavalry
battles were a real-life thing like I
thought they made it up for the show but
when I was looking into it know this is
very very real the two events that I'd
like to see replace the cavalry battle
and the obstacle course would be a tug
of war and a relay race
in the next generation team events are
more important than ever because the
winners of the festival will have to
work in a team together and represent
you on the global stage
I imagine that a quark powered relay
race and a quiet power tug-of-war I mean
it would be so epic and it would
obviously require a lot of you know
teamwork and coordination so yeah I
personally those are my favorites but do
let me know if you have any other good
ideas down below once those events are
done only 16 students will be remaining
for the final event which is a fighting
tournament in my opinion this is the one
thing that shouldn't change from the
first sports festival just a one on one
you know
all-out battle with your quirks that is
way more entertaining than any other
kind of gimmick you can think of of all
the kids we've seen so far which to be
honest isn't that many we would have
tamashiro definitely there
arrey for sure Kazuma the tongue tank
kid the assault dust kid the hula-hoop
kid and then 9 more kids who we don't
know about yet because let's be honest
not everyone's gonna be from that same
elementary school and the final
remaining place would go to Kota who's
another character who would have had a
crazy quirk evolution by this point and
I'll explained why he would have had
this in a second as we know it now
Kurtis quirk enables him to emit water
from his hands but as we know his
parents were the pro heroes known as
water hose that hero name is important
because it implies that they could both
emit water at a high pressure and this
is supported by the fact that they
messed up musculars face leaving him
with a scar and also missing an eye so
that means at a minimum teenage Kota
would be able to emit water from his
hands at a very high pressure if he was
to apply this correctly and you know
with the right training then he could
use this high pressured water to give
himself the power of flight think of it
like this jetpack video only instead of
the water coming out a jetpack is coming
out of his hands instead last thing I
want to mention on his quark upgrade was
that similar to how gettin' can
manipulate the temperature of his eyes
Kota should be able to alter be
temperature of his water that would come
in super handy I mean imagine if he was
able to admit boiling hot water that
would be pretty damn lethal the reason
why I think Kota would have to have an
amazing quad evolution similar to this
is because as I mentioned in part one
he's a full year younger than arey
and a few of you in the commets
mentioned how we could maybe join the
school year early but I was thinking
like obviously in order to do that you
need to demonstrate some kind of
exceptional skill that shows that you're
capable of joining japan's top year of
school a year earlier than you should
now when the matchups begin a battle
that we'd have to see is kota against
Kazuma or as i like to call it the deku
derby unlike Kazuma curses quirk gives
him long range capabilities meaning that
he can fire a quick attack right from
the jump similar to what we saw from
Todoroki for example he could blast two
fountains of hot water from each of his
hands which come crashing towards his
classmate because cat Zoomer doesn't
have an attack based quirk he would have
likely trained his body to be more agile
and compensate for his lack of offensive
power on that basis as soon as the match
begins
he'd have to activate that super move
that I was talking about earlier and
then immediately attempt to dodge the
water remember that although he can't be
physically hurt for about 60 seconds the
sheer force and pressure of the water
can still physically push him out the
ring if Kazuma was successful in dodging
that attack his superior physical
strength could enable him to quite
quickly reach Kota and begin to push him
out of the ring however thanks to the
immense amount of water pressure that
Kota is now able to harness he can use
his hands to propel himself into the air
and kind of like flip over Kazuma and he
could do this to quickly readjust
himself so that he's facing consumers
back and once he's in position he can
deliver his strongest possible blast of
water to force consumer out of the ring
Kota would likely be the victor of this
matchup although in theory maybe
consumers cell activation quirk could
perhaps maybe enable him to reach a
level of speed and strength that's
beyond the level of what can be achieved
by normal training if something like
that was the case then maybe he would be
able to take Kota by surprise and also
react quicker to the attempts to push
him out the ring the next battle is one
that I think should and would be the
final of the entire US sports festival
and that is of course
arrey against tamashiro as I said in
part one he would have been training
with Aizawa for almost a decade at this
point so while quark would have evolved
far beyond what we know of it currently
a cool idea that I had is that she would
be able to invert the use of her quirk
rather than rewinding things she can
also fast-forward things and if applied
in a spatial way she can fast-forward
herself into different positions this is
another black level reference but I feel
that Julius his movements in this scene
best represent what I'm trying to
explain on top of that he would now have
her power pretty much under control
for example if tamashiro was to send a
bingeing ball directly at arey she could
swipe her hand and make it evaporate and
just disappear out of existence
obviously super overpowered but I mean
that's that's what I quark is anyway so
how would this fight go down much like
back ago tamashiro loves equality and
would show an equal level of
mercilessness whether he's up against
male or female contestants his army of
bingeing balls would charge full speed
of arey
and due to the sheer volume of them
there's no way that a few balls aren't
making a little bit of contact that
being said Ares fastforward ability
would be enough to get past the initial
wave of bingeing balls and it would put
her just a couple of meters away from
where tamashiro is standing when
thinking about potential upgrades for
his quark naturally the speed of the
balls and the biasing ability those
would be enhanced but it would also make
sense if he could manipulate the size to
create these massive chain chomps to
defend him with those two massive balls
both standing in his way I mean you
wouldn't even be able to see him let
alone touch him so airy wouldn't be able
to actually get to tamashiro
until she realized those two big balls
out of existence but in the time it
takes her to swipe them away it can
leave an opening for tamashiro
to send her flying backwards with a
bingeing ball straight to the chest
he could then run towards arey and as
she's a bit confused from being taken by
surprise he could then try to throw out
the ring like back ago did two Todoroki
one thing that's important to remember
is that Ares quark is an accumulation
type accumulation types need to build up
an element or substance over a period of
time in order for them to work in the
case of fat gum he needs to build up his
fat so that he can use his quark but in
Ares case we still have no idea what the
element or substance that she needs to
build up actually is but whatever it is
throughout the entire sports festival
she would have been using it up you know
in the relay race in a tug-of-war and in
the first three rounds of the fighting
tournament she would have been using up
she's accumulated because of this area
is at a massive disadvantage in the
final and she would need to expend the
last of her rerun quark to stop herself
getting thrown out of the ring she's
effectively fighting Quercus at this
point if he's quick which I'm sure he is
tamashiro could materialize a bingeing
ball and then grab on to it if the ball
could propel itself forwards towards
arey
and pull tamashiro along for the ride
given that he'd likely have more
momentum than airy not to mention the
fact that he probably be heavier than
she is once they clash in the middle of
the arena he'd be able to pin her to the
ground which would render him the winner
of the sports festival although a lot of
that is obviously a bit lucky due to the
fact that area has a quirk that needs to
accumulate something and then
progressively runs out as the day goes
on remember that you don't actually need
to knock your opponent out the ring
you can also immobilize them or just get
them to say they give up or just make
them pass out whichever works naturally
Airy would never give up but given her
quirk at this point would have all but
run out once she's pinned to the ground
it's basically game over all the
matchups that I'd like to see would be
the assault dust kid versus Kota and
also the tongue tank kid versus Airy one
match in particular that I think would
be really messy would be tamashiro up
against the who hoop kid I mean you just
have a bunch of people throwing stuff
across the stage there would be a mess
by the time those two have finished when
everything said and done I think the
four students to represent us first
years on the global stage would be
tamashiro as Captain every the assault
dust kid and you know likely someone
that we don't already know but if we
have to pick someone that we do know I'm
gonna say Kota all I'm saying is there
are many kids in the world of my
academia that we just do not know
anything about yet just before we finish
the video I like to say thank you to
this commenter for giving me the initial
inspiration for the idea of an
international sports festival I kind of
took the idea and ran with it but thank
you for the initial concept also
shout-out to Tristan who sent me this
awesome art of Deku that he drew after I
did the first part of this video much
appreciated
thanks for watching as always and peace
out